au
lieu du gauche au point
soit super six qui vient de tendre avec
le sourire que vous imaginez facilement
le tour hier de triomphe qui est en
train de serrer la main de tes amis et
je vois qu'ils se préparent à parler
dans un instant vous entendez le premier
ministre de la province de québec
mesdames les électrices et messieurs les
électeurs de l'épreuve québec le
gouvernement de l'union nationale et le
gouvernement et toutes les populations
des provinces et nous voulons travailler
la main dans la main avec les amis de
l'union nationale et 17h16 l'asm
continue à faire de la province très
prospère habité par une population
heureuse mais qui veut dire homme et du
bel appétit
[Musique]